is this code on a virus for me like a
couple of weeks Apple oh it's gonna be a
couple of months apples let me know so I
can start mother cracking up on foods
and Montclair swab could move to mother
Antarctica the corona virus is obviously
very real you guys so first of all be
safe
wash your hands do your part self
quarantine if you need to but also super
weird pop culture somehow a sort of
predicted that coronavirus would happen
the US government has lost its
credibility so it's borrowing some of
mine
yep in this 2007 clip from The Simpsons
this Tom Hanks character played by Tom
Hanks
calls out the government and needs to be
isolated this is Tom Hanks saying if you
see me in person please leave me be of
course this is insanely bizarre because
Tom Hanks revealed that he and his wife
Rita Wilson have both tested positive
for coronavirus and are currently
quarantined in Australia their son Chad
shared a video message on Instagram
Wednesday I just got off the phone with
them they both are fine they're not even
that sick they're not worried about it
they're not trippin but they're going
through the necessary health precautions
obviously eerie and let's not forget the
1996 film Space Jam predicting an NBA
shutdown after meeting with team owners
I have decided that until we can
guarantee the health and safety of our
NBA players there will be no more
basketball this season on Wednesday the
NBA announced a suspension of the NBA
season after Utah player Rudy Gobert
tested positive for the infectious
disease and then there's Kim Kardashian
she posted this excerpt from a 2008
Sylvia brown book quote in around 2020 a
severe pneumonia like illness will
spread throughout the globe attacking
the lungs and the bronchial tubes and
resisting all known treatments almost
more baffling than the illness itself
will be the fact that it will suddenly
vanish as quickly as it arrived at
again 10 years later and then disappear
completely truly wild but always one to
try and be helpful Kim has also been
sharing tips for navigating the
coronavirus so we have a doctor here and
I'm wearing Cesar and I'm gonna show the
new appropriate way to say hello care
I'll do it oh you guys - that's it you
should not do elbows because you cough
into your elbow so no more elbows or
just do a little bow I think that would
be nice
yep so doc Chloe handed this to me but I
don't want to touch it cuz she handed it
to me do you have any sanitizer can we
wipe that down white Clorox wipes so he
definitely has them I cannot give that
to my daughter and if you're looking for
an expert opinion
et was recently with dr. oz who shared a
bit more insight into the corona virus
is the virus really airborne viruses
definitely airborne that virus seems to
live on inanimate objects I think the
the survival rate is going to be pretty
close to the traditional fashion flu but
when you get it into the older age
groups and people have cardiovascular
disease or diabetes or I just got past
cancer have bad lungs then those folks
are really at increased risk and they're
the ones I want to protect if we can
keep them free then we're gonna have a
very low mortality rate seriously stay
safe out there do your part wash your
hands and for all the latest stick with
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]